dan my question would be around how most
macro analysts are looking at this in
general right you've been involved in
the space for a long time and obviously
looking at the macro side for for a long
time also how have those conversations
changed over the last decade with uh
kind of what we'll call traditional
macro investors
over the last decade i thought you were
going to ask over the last month or two
with the discussion
maybe the last year is better
yeah no but i'll i'll start with the
first part i mean i would say that look
the number of asymmetric opportunities
uh in the 90s and 2000s uh you know were
enormous i mean you had all sorts of um
fundamental misalignments the erm crisis
um
uh was one our crisis that you know the
big convergence trade in europe was um
really um
you know an exercise in understanding
how politics uh can uh influence
economics but in in the wrong way and
then at the end of the day
uh the fundamental
macro the economics ended up uh you know
in in some cases prevailing and not in
not in others but you had these big
fundamental misalignments the same thing
with the asian crisis in in 97
and of course you know the big big
difference um is that most of the macro
guys so all the guys that you know you
know by reputation
almost all of them made a substantial i
don't want to say all of their money but
certainly at least 70 to 80 of their
money as a result of bond yields falling
from their peak in ninth in the early
1980s and so you know if you start in
1991 92 93 the two-year note was
yielding eight percent
i mean the japanese two-year note was
yielding you know i don't even know now
nor certainly north of five percent and
so you had
very easy
bets um to make in a sense you could
borrow money in the repo markets
overnight at a lower rate that you can
invest
uh in those two-year notes
and you know basically some of those
guys they they wrote those two-year
notes for 20 years all the way to zero
and with almost infinite leverage
because when you buy
bonds the margin that you need to put
down with your prime broker is
practically zero and so if you weren't a
macro guide benefiting from that drop in
interest rates uh you're an equity guy
who is benefiting from uh those drop uh
the drop in the expansion in
um you know um in the multiples that
happen in the equity market right so
um in one sense that entire macro game
was based on that drop and again that
was driven by an aberration
uh really in the 70s where we had this
spikey inflation and they raised rates
to you know abnormal levels and so we
had a 20 or 25 year period
disinflationary period where all the
central bankers sort of you know lived
in fear uh they're all fighting the last
battle in a sense so they kept policy
very tight uh in my view uh interest
rate policy was much tighter than it
should have been
uh for for many many years and so and
again that you know culminated in in
some ways in the crisis in 08 and since
08 we've had permanently low yields
because there's been too much debt
accumulated in the system
um and there you know also the advent of
i would say technology
has been a permanent disinflationary
force and i think it'll be interesting
going forward now
whether that reasserts itself we've had
spikey inflation because the money
supplies
have exploded post the covid uh giveaway
which started in march of 20. i think
it's going to be hard for them to pull
it back
very importantly i would say going
forward is look negative real interest
rates are seven percent okay so that the
the overnight rate is around zero and
cpi is seven percent is seven percent so
that means the cash you hold in your
bank is worth minus seven percent a year
okay
um i think that it's going to take years
and years for the federal reserve to
bring on tight policy
you know i type policy in my mind would
be having the interest rate over the cpi
rate in march of 2000 the the two-year
note was uh six percent and the cpi was
three percent right so that was three
percent positive real yield in the
two-year that's that's tight policy
we're now completely the opposite way um
so i i actually am quite positive um you
know medium term on uh on the markets on
you know the traditional let's just say
the equity market i don't really focus
too much on the legacy world anymore um
i you know very positive of course on
bitcoin ethereum the digital asset
ecosystem all those new use cases that
whole world growing up
um
you know very positive on that world
and
you know look um
this whole discussion and this is to
your last part of your question about
you know the last few months and the fed
um you know the fed just mentions that
it's going to
raise interest rates and you know we
lose 15 trillion dollars off the market
cap of global stock markets so
in a sense i think the stock market
really already kind of tightened
liquidity for the fed
and i think as they
um you know as they raise rates look in
my mind as a investor i don't make any
differentiation between a zero interest
rate and a one percent interest rate or
even a two percent interest rate
so
um and then you know pop i would wonder
what your opinion is about this but you
look at the yields in the stable coin
market you know you get seven eight
percent in the dae on a stable coin you
know what in in you know for goodness
sake what are you doing
owning legacy market uh legacy world
bond markets you know 200 trillion
dollars of bonds
in the legacy world
basically yielding less than two percent
when you got a seven to nine percent uh
yield in the stable point mark